there's three main sticking points that
guys come to us with the first is
approach anxiety
that feeling of being not good enough
going in with that negative
mindset she's going to say no she's busy
i'm not going to be her type you know a
million excuses so they're starting off
already
on the wrong foot and that affects their
energy their vibe their body language
everything
the second one is uh conversation skills
just being able to express themselves
with confidence and authentically the
third one
is getting stuck in the comfort zone we
call it which is just not escalating in
any way at all not
showing his intent not flirting the most
common one out of those three and where
all kind of lies
is that conversation skill essentially
that transition from opening line
getting her full attention emotionally
and mentally i mean that's that
transition
it's very very difficult to achieve
i'm joined by kezia noble kezia welcome
to the show
hello hello how are you i'm fine thank
you how are you
very good thank you what do you do for a
job describe your job for me
i'm a dating and attraction expert men
dating an attraction expert for men so
not for women
that would be the blind leading the
blind all right okay
okay i get i get that i've noticed this
online upon doing a little bit of
research for this
it appears there's a lot of women
teaching men to date
why is that the case why is it that
women are teaching men today and not men
teaching men to date
um okay so my research says the complete
opposite
is that there's more men teaching guys
to to attract and date um i do
think that there are some women who are
now you know
doing their thing i think that's quite
recent
um but i actually know a lot more guys
that do this
than women um i think maybe um
i think the guys get a lot of bad press
unfortunately uh the media seems to want
to crucify
pick up artists pick up anything related
to pick up
and if you're a woman you you
um they're more having a bit sympathetic
um to you teaching this which is just
totally unfair i mean it's good for me
but i'll say it is unfair because a lot
of these guys i think um
are providing a service it's interesting
that the end result is the same thing
the end result is getting men to be
better data's
more effective at being attractive but
because
a girl's delivering it it's somehow less
cd less what yeah less cd
um it's like an easy target isn't it
it's like okay if a guy's teaching
another guy
you know the media the general public
believe you know oh he's untrustworthy
that word like seduction it sounds very
um very contrived
um he must be using tricks and um he
must be
lying to her on some level whereas if a
woman is
teaching it and she's not actually going
out and applying and demonstrating it
that's okay because it's in the abstract
almost
um it's it's more kind of like well it's
theory rather than she's going out and
doing it
it's interesting that i i find it
fascinating that there's a branding
problem for men
teaching men to pick up women
and you've managed to get this
competitive advantage so fair play to
you fair play to you well done
for being born that gender and yeah it's
great huh
yeah for sure so first things first
where do you see
men going wrong the most when dating and
trying to attract women
um well let's let's look at the most
common um sticking points that guys come
to us with and what i see in general
when guys are approaching me or my
friends
there's three main sticking points that
guys come to us with the first is
approach anxiety
and that feeling of being not good
enough um
going in with that negative mindset
she's gonna say no
she's busy i'm not gonna be her type she
probably likes black guys she probably
likes white guys
you know a million excuses so they're
starting off already
on the wrong foot and that affects their
energy their vibe their body language
everything
that's the first one the second one is
conversation skills just being able to
express themselves with confidence and
authentically
um guys will often talk to a woman with
a nice sky filter on i call it it's a
filter
um so they they're sort of playing not
to lose rather than playing to win
they um just go in there and be very
safe
the conversation will be very safe
they'll say the same kind of generic
stuff that everyone else says
um and then at the end of it they kind
of feel like well that wasn't me it was
that was a poor representation of who i
am in fact that wasn't me at all that
was a very watered down version of me
and that's like if we put a filter on
anything it gives a kind of nice
effect but it's not impactful
and um as i said it's it's an authentic
so i think a massive part of it is just
guys running out of things to say
not saying anything impactful not making
a connection
and the girl loses interest very very
quickly
she makes a decision it's kind of like
when he does actually say something
quite interesting mentally she's already
checked out
and it's very difficult to um you know
make
impact later on um the third one
is getting stuck in the comfort zone we
call it which is just not escalating in
any way at all
not showing his intent not flirting this
kind of comes
the second point which is a nice sky
filter which
waters down your character your boldness
your charm just waters everything down
and it goes back to the idea of playing
not to lose
you know not taking any risk at all um
and then having a very platonic
conversation with the girl so the girl's
kind of thinking well you know
does he like me does he not and if he
does like me he's not showing much
intent
um so i don't really know where this is
going so i'd say that
most of the sticking points that we have
will fall under one of those three
categories
but uh the most common one out of those
three and where all kind of lies
is that conversation skills that
essentially that transition
from opening line to getting her full
attention emotionally and mentally i
mean that's that transition
it's very very difficult to achieve
that's so interesting i can see both in
my own experiences and in the ones of my
friends
you might not know i'm a nightclub
promoters i've watched about a million
drunk people go in and out of venues
obviously
one of the main reasons that people go
out is that they're perhaps single
perhaps looking for a partner
just you know whether that be serious or
casual
um and up to the girls that are
listening right you might be thinking oh
am i going to listen to a lot of dating
tips for guys for
but i want to hear throughout this
conversation as kezzy is bringing up
these sorts of things i want to hear if
you've noticed this so just leave it in
the comments below or give me a dm
um about whether or not you're noticing
this whether or not you have these guys
that come up to you and just have this
real vanilla personality
like whether or not you think that all
guys or the vast majority of guys have
nothing to say
whereas it might actually just be the
case that they are selecting for a
particular type of guy
who is nervous around you because you're
a pretty girl and you've got
pretty friends with you and you're
dolled up and you've got your hair done
and
that blokes really we we go out as a
group
but like you don't before we were going
out we probably had our jeans on
backwards
you know we probably didn't really think
too much about what we were going to
wear and then you're there you know
fully done up so i'd love to hear what
girl's experiences of being on the
receiving end of the sort of things that
we're going to go through today
i like um so first things first how do
guys get over approach anxiety
if you don't go and speak to the girl
you don't
even get the opportunity to say
something that's totally [ __ ] to her
so it's a two-pronged assault that we
use um on this
approach anxiety the first is actually
getting numb to the sensation of fear
i'm a big believer in numbing out
rejection
uh overcoming it i think overcoming a
fear of rejection
it's difficult when i did a video about
this in fact and i waffled on in it so
much because it's very very complex
how to really overcome rejection i don't
believe that you truly can overcome
not so much the fear but um
i know i don't want to waffle on here so
i'm just reigning in a little bit
um it's becoming numb to that feeling of
fear so the more you do something you
get rejected a few times
hurts and then basically you numb to it
you become desensitized to it
and that's when i say the kind of fog
lifts a little
bit and you start taking better risks
and you start becoming um
a lot more how can i put it
level-headed about the whole approach so
if you are going into an interaction
and you're like um you know [ __ ] it i'm
just gonna do it i'm not gonna think
about it
and then she rejects you that can still
hurt you
but after a while it numbs
and you have clarity that's what i'm
looking for you have like clarity
okay so i don't feel the pain anymore
what do i need to do
next you start asking the right
questions if you're coming from a place
of like
anger like well [ __ ] her she you know am
i allowed to swear on you
swear away fire away as much as you can
apologies
totally fine so um if you're going in
the
attitude which is oh i hope she likes me
i don't want to be hurt
okay that's a fog in your head if you're
going in with a kind of like [ __ ] you i
don't care if you like me or not you're
going in with anger
that's a fog you can't get clarity you
can't work out what to do next
when you are numb to something you start
asking the right questions
okay what do i need to do to improve
what
maybe it's that maybe i need to adjust
this slightly
can't do that when you're you're caught
up in that fog of anxiety
and you know fear and hate and um
feeling inadequate just fog so we we do
that get them to go up talk to girls
actually
get over the physical reaction
of the anxiety but then we go
sort of backwards so a big fear that
guys have when i speak to them
is not even the rejection it's it's
actually the fear of running out
something to say
that awkward moment they're sort of not
even at that point of thinking about
rejection
right now they're sometimes thinking but
i've got nothing to say to her
uh but what if she says this and i don't
know how to respond
if you know if you become a master
conversationalist and you know look
it doesn't matter what she throws at me
doesn't matter what she can come to [ __ ]
off and i'll make it work
she can tell me that she's from a
country i've never heard of and i will
i will um say something that will
absolutely you know capture her
imagination and it will what make her
want to invest in me
i can trigger her curiosity with ev
whatever she gives me if you have
that kind of level of skill the approach
anxiety
decreases because you're you already
know
look no matter what i'm gonna have an
interesting conversation with this
person
so what that's what we do like this is
my seven-day mastery program we used to
just
kind of start off with helping them
overcome approach anxiety as i said just
going out there getting numb to it
and then i realized no we should be
doing conversation skills simultaneously
because they're going to get to this
point where they overcome the approach
anxiety you're going to talk to a woman
and it'll be like oh [ __ ] i've got
nothing to say
and then guess
yes absolutely so honestly the best
thing that you can do is become a master
conversationalist
become brilliant to say whatever she
throws at me have it all like
lined up she says this to me she does
that to me i got it
i got this i'm not i'm gonna capitalize
on whatever she says and i know how to
do it
so a lot of students come to me like i
just want to freestyle and feel you know
authentic i'm like good luck
good luck with that um sometimes you do
need those kind of
go-to lines and that go to sequence
almost
at the early stages just to get you
through that horrible sort of transition
point where everything's very awkward um
so canned openers are a
a big sort of artifact of the old pickup
artistry world right
like that was one of the things i think
to have like the
first you gotta go in then neg the
beater then do this and it just harks
massively
back to um the magic days of
history yeah yeah you know like it just
it harks back to that and i think that's
again like as i'm hearing this kind of
whatever it is third wave uh
relationship
dating advice for men now or whatever it
is as i'm hearing this come out i'm
starting to see the development of that
right so it used to be
having these canned openers and getting
over approach anxiety avoiding getting
kb'd and knocked back and all this sort
of stuff
um but you've identified here that in
order to kind of get your foot in the
door
you need to have something that assists
you in overcoming that approach anxiety
a safety net i love that so
perfect example this will be episode 200
and something
of this podcast right i've done 300 400
hours of this podcast
i still get nervous before every single
one because i don't want to say
a stupid thing at the very very start
i'll speak to some
professor from princeton i'm never going
to speak to again
unless we become best friends which
happens a lot but i'll speak to some guy
but i still don't want to look like a
fool to him and inevitably the people
that are listening which could be the
girl's
friends that have sat around her so the
way i have got a tip for you oh so
you've got a tip yourself go on
don't hear this i just i prep the first
question
the only question which is fully
scripted on this show
is the first question because i just
want to get i'm like right okay if i
nail that first
very first question i'm over it we're
into the conversation and then it's just
a game of spontaneity
what i find interesting is that you've
said
relying too much on spontaneous wit is
actually
potentially going to be a little bit of
a downfall when you're dating
i can i just yes you're right but
there's just one caveat to that
there are people who are naturally witty
they're fine
they're good to go i'm talking about
people who find conversation very
awkward and most people
do most people just are not they're
interesting people they've got character
they've got a lot going for them but
they're just not engaging when it comes
to conversation they don't know how they
just hung around the same people
all the time they haven't developed
those skills okay
um it's like a beautiful woman most
beautiful women that i personally know
don't have much banter because they've
had to rely on their beauty
so you know that that's what they've had
to do uh the
the the girls that are not so attractive
have had to rely on their sex appeal
their
their wit their banter which is why by
the way when you go to a strip club
the girl that is cleaning up the most is
the least attractive one
she's using her head she's using her
banter and whip
um that's the fact every single strip
club you go to you'll see that the least
attractive or like one of the less
attractive physically attractive women
are doing much better than the really
stunning girl who just relying purely on
her looks
i digress um uh back to the point
uh that's saying okay so if you're a
witty person then it's fine but most
people
are not they're not used to um you know
being in those situations where they
have like
literally three or four minutes to
really make impact
um and market their attributes keep her
interested connect with her all this
stuff that they're trying to remember
so i have these kind of things like
conversational click-bait
things like that little things i throw
in there i never told them to lie by the
way i never ever tell them to lie
um and so i give them conversational
click bait and i said look if you use
this
it will be a great way for you to
express your
attributes your selling points
essentially um
but it also really um
spark her curiosity and interest and and
get her to invest in you
i'm good conversations but i still rely
on go to live sometimes if i think that
i need to
you know i need to seriously make a bit
of impact with this person
i will have my go-to lines even now
so i don't think there's anything wrong
with that
i've only seen it help that's all i've
seen it's helped people and then when
you get really good and you become
confident because it's like a positive
feedback loop
you start getting better responses you
start going oh okay
i don't need that anymore i can use my
own thing good good use your own thing
please get rid of my stuff as soon as
possible and use your own stuff that's
what i want you to do but it's those
early stages it's a bit like uh
what kids they have those bicycles and
stabilizers behind and eventually you
get rid of them
but they do need those stabilizers to
build up the confidence to get on a bike
first right
yes i wonder how many of the girls are
having a visceral reaction
uh that makes them feel uncomfortable at
the potential
for the opening line that a guy gives
them to be something which wasn't
actually
designed for them because oh i don't
give opening lines sorry
um very very let me just make that
really really clear
what i'm talking about here is the
transition from opening line so some
guys said to me what should i say they
will say anything to her
you know ask her what time it is or tell
her where she got her tan from
i don't know tell her she looks good but
what you do the data that she gives you
that is what i care about okay so the
magic is in
scaling that from it just being hi i'm
here look at me i'm a person
to this is now a conversation and a
dialogue that's the really important
part a lot of guys come through i just
need that
magic opening line i'm like i've got
great opening lines don't get me wrong
it's gonna it's gonna make it go oh
that's interesting and you're gonna
gain her attention but what do you do
with the data that she exchanges
because you know conversation is an
exchange of data
a lot of guys forget that they just
start going into interrogation mode
and the reason is because they're trying
because they're trying to find
the answer that they want ain't going to
happen
she's not into the same stuff as you
commonality football
i've never heard of a girl so i slept
with him because he supports the
football team
yeah you never know you never know i
love listen i can do something now i
love
dogs i love dogs i'm a you know
dog phone i don't like cats like dogs
i'm telling you no not a single guy
has who said i love dogs too i've slept
with him based on that
it's never happened but a lot of guys
think
oh as long as i find out one thing
[Music]
i'm just all of these are just open
loops because you saw all that we're
doing is opening loops and i want to
know
from the thousands of people that are
listening have you ever slept with
someone because you both like the same
animal because someone will have done
something
oh my god you're a parakeet person i'm a
parakeet person too
and then that's it that's the beginning
of a flourishing
beginning no no it can be the beginning
like okay
that's something we have in common then
what do we do with it next and it goes
on and it starts going into different
conversations and and it becomes a very
sort of multi-dimensional kind of
interaction
very dynamic interaction yes but i don't
think anyone's going to say
well because you know we both like the
same
you know fillings in our sandwich
that use the same washing detergent
that's it that's that could be the basis
for it
yeah exactly whisk me away where's the
uber um
okay so that's how someone can get over
approach anxiety and i guess it's
interesting that that leads
into both the second and third aspects
right the
run out of something to say and then the
what did you call it like
upscaling or the advancing the
conversation to like show you
escalating that's it yes upscaling
[ __ ] hell
marketing too much marketing uh it's all
about
things no no you don't get me what i
teach is essentially marketing
i say to them you're the product go sell
yourself
um and they first of all say to me
students i don't know what my qualities
are well that's a bad start how can you
sell yourself if you don't know what
your qualities are
without an offering man you gotta have
the offering look it's all about it's
either traffic or it's conversions
that's all that i'm bothered about
that's what we've been saying for years
trafficking conversions
um okay so we've got that we've got past
the first bit we understand
that um we can get past our approach
anxiety with some
chosen exposure right with deliberate
practice
so that the fear of rejection and again
like to the guys that are listening
you know the feeling i don't know why
it's so terrifying i don't know if girls
can appreciate this
they probably can but it is it's the
same feeling as standing on the edge of
a very very big drop
sometimes before you go up and speak to
a girl like it's like a
mortal danger it feels like you're in
you're potentially going to die
that you're about to get ready for a
fight
i think that for guys rejection
comments massively on who we are
it's wired into us evolutionarily we
don't want to be rejected either by
a woman or by the tribe generally um
one of men's biggest fears is rejection
right you don't want to feel silly
i know i'm asking you i'm just getting
inside your head that's all because um
it's a it's a big one we have a bomb we
had a student who was a bomb disposal
expert he could
that he could do that job but he
couldn't approach women
that is so good police we have firemen
[ __ ] i couldn't do i'm alone run to a
fire i see a fire run the other way
bomb disposal expert yeah he was he's
actually on
we've got a video of him saying that as
well that is intense
but you know that's perfect example and
again like
girls you might think i go on a night
out i make all of this effort i
i do this that and the other and guys
don't ever come up and talk to me
it might just be that you keep going to
places where guys are [ __ ] scared of you
because
that's probably the most most likely
reason that guys might not be coming up
and talking to you
i think it's gotten worse though i think
it's gotten worse
why um well there's a few reasons
there's a few reasons men
and i remember you know i've been i've
been
i was going to nightclubs at like 13 14.
and you know i i was 40 i was a bit too
young being in those nightclubs
but i would watch i would watch and i
saw men approaching a lot this is in the
90s
okay i see men approaching women are
not i see women getting hit on all the
time in fact and then you know as i got
older it started happening to me and my
friends
um but the more i went to clubs and more
i found that
i don't want to say men are becoming
[ __ ] that would be that would be
um no i would no i would never say that
but
uh hmm it's to do with
massive part of it with apps bloody
dating apps
i think that's a big problem with it
people are getting very used to using
dating apps
i don't think men are [ __ ] but i
think society has tried to pussify men
um i mean a perfect example of this is
the fact that
it's challenging for a man to teach
another man to date
without it somehow being labeled as
being seedy but the hustle yeah i mean
the media is totally
society media you know there's a mad
witch hunt going on
been going on since even before me too
it's been a kind of
thing like it's a strange thing i think
i i personally i don't want to get too
crazy with this tin you know tin hat
foil
tin foil hats tin foil hat
on you but i think the media is made up
social media a lot of these people in
the tech i think a lot of them
are men who are no good with women
they're like uber geeks
uber uber geeks we're talking about
always been shipped with women
don't want to see other guys doing well
with women i think
personally i think it's like this big
conspiracy theory it's just trying to
make men into kind of very um effeminate
but like pussify them there's wrong for
wanting women you're wrong for
objectifying women
hello i don't mind being objectified i
have no problem with it
i think the dynamic between the sexes
definitely appears to be
very different you know as someone who's
32 so i've been able to see
a clubbing from 2005
until 2020 so i got a pretty pretty good
sample
yeah you do i've got even more ahead of
you i mean i started clubbing in the 90s
and i'm getting it
even to be honest in 2005 men were
approaching women still
but you see now they're looking at
phones and looking at the apps
um it's kind of like an easy way to meet
women everyone says it's a shortcut it's
not actually a shortcut because i don't
use dating apps i'm single right now i'm
divorced
and i'm a single mom so i should do
those dating apps more than anyone
i refuse to go to dating apps you know
why because i see all my friends going
wasting so much time with dating apps i
was like hold on this is going to be a
short cut
they're like no go on day after day like
oh i've never had that
problem because every guy that i've gone
on a date with i've already met because
he he came and approached me or however
how introduced to me
so i i met him already and i got a sense
and that's very important a sense of who
someone is it's a fill
it's the body language is it a bit off
what's that eye contact like what's
their manner
you know you sense people and when you
go on the date with them
it can be a let down of course we've had
all have bad date experiences but on the
whole
it's you you don't it's not such a big
leap as meeting someone that
you've only seen a photograph of so
actually these people who say it's a
shortcut
i'm hearing more that they're wasting
time on dates and drinks
people that as soon as they meet and
they go this is not the person that was
in that photograph
i don't mean physically i'm not talking
physically is another thing no one looks
like their photographs anymore not me
not you not anyone
we're all filtered and and people just
go up like that when they see us
but um i'm talking about the sense of
confidence because people are
very very you know gun-ho witty with
those text messages you know
they're very funny very confident and
then you meet them think
he's the same person because it's easy
to write easy to write something
and re-edit and think about it and when
you actually meet someone one-on-one for
a day
completely different i think that's a
big part of it i do think it's that's a
big part i think there's a media
kind of um is it
uh not motive what's the word a media um
agenda agenda um against
men uh women are also
i think making it difficult for men how
um well i have a lot of students and
this is more happening i found in places
like
san francisco where there's a big kind
of woke movement going on
um and a lot of sort of um
feminists and they're telling me like
but this is what they're telling me
i mean i'm just giving you secondhand
information here
that um you know if you just open up a
door for a woman
and they're getting shouted at
shout out to that by opening a door for
a woman so i can do that myself
i think i think that's very toxic to do
that to have those kind of reactions to
people who could just be being polite
not even interested in you
i think that's kind of spreading a
little bit most women are okay most
women if you go speak to them
they'll be fine you know but um
there is something i think that's been
um
been been cut been changing for quite a
while now
why do you think i'm very curious to
know why do you think men are
approaching women less
than the 1970s or 80s i can't speak for
for that long ago but i think
apps and the uh proliferation of people
spending time online
generally more of our social time is now
spent
it's just just generally you know like
people
guys talking to guys girls talking to
girls it happens less because more of
our communication is done through our
phones
which inevitably is going to skew people
toward being better online and worse
offline so that's that's part of it
that's the big one i agree that's
that's the big one because it's just a
skill at the end of the day having a
conversation with someone is just a
skill
but if you don't converse all that much
you know
you can have people who i've gone weeks
i'm sure that you might have done as
well if you've just been head down in
the funnel hole or in your marketing
hole
do any bits and pieces if you're not
careful you can actually go long periods
of days without saying a word to anyone
except for like thank you to the
checkout server
yeah and you get rusty don't you you get
socially very rusty but what do you
think about the whole um
media movement you know that that kind
of making guys into the enemy that whole
me too thing i don't want to get too
much into that but i
i've thought a lot about this over the
last year the last couple of years
i think that it's challenging to hold
in reality at the same time that the
metoo movement
has been borne out of a very toxic
system that was obviously happening
happening in hollywood and women who
quite rightly need to be heard
and at the same time that typical
masculine traits
and the fact that men are the
protagonists in the dating market
for a reason because that is every
man every male species on the planet bar
like
a penguin and a a [ __ ] parakeet or
something
men are the protagonists sexually that
is what happens
men go up to women and as
girls and the metoo movement perhaps
sometimes push that domain of what is
fair
um outside of you know someone tries to
open the door for somebody and
whatever it is now seventh wave feminism
whatever we're up to um
perhaps pushes pushes this rhetoric a
little bit too hard men
quite rightly only have one response
which is to go right well [ __ ] it
like if that's the way that you want to
be i'm just going to leave leave it i
had douglas murray on the show
and he was talking about a friend
phenomenal guy you'd love the episode
had him on the show when he was talking
about his friend's son and his friend's
son is like
18 or something 17 18. so you'd be
thinking like just about to hit the
straps with women like really really
like hitting the ground running
and he asked his friend and he said so
is he
is your son dating and he's like oh no
he wants nothing to do with women and
he's like because
douglas is gay so he can say this and
he's like oh my god he's
he's not [ __ ] gay is he he's not gay
he's not got that he's not good that is
his future has he
and um he was like no no no he just
thinks that they're far more trouble
than they're worth
doesn't want anything to do with them
just thinks that they're far more
trouble than they're worth
and leaves them be and like that is for
everyone for both sides of the aisle
that's a terrible situation for us to be
[ __ ] it's really really [ __ ] um for me
what really did it was that
gillette advert i mean that was
atrocious such an
advert you remember the one i had sargon
of akkad on here talking
precisely well i won't i won't be an
echo but it was just the one scene that
got me
all the whole experience got me and i'm
i
i have a son so um i'm telling you now
boys like to fight
it's not society boys choose to fight
okay even if you have the most peace
loving hippie family
boys fight okay that's it that's what
they're like wrong will write i don't
know but it's a natural
instinct in boys girls don't do it so
much anyway
it was a bit when a woman was walking by
and
the man went up to approach her and the
other guy stood in front of him like
no don't approach her but you don't know
what that guy was going to say he could
have
they could have got married as a result
who is that man to come along and say
no you can't approach her i bet you that
man and i know i know it's just an
advert and i'm looking into this but i
bet you if that was in your life that
man's married
he's got his life sorted out the other
guy single
tough [ __ ] tough [ __ ] um
and that really got me really really
angry i feel like almost living in a
harvest kind of society it's like men
and women can't talk to each other
get the [ __ ] out of it and go to saudi
arabia really go
live there where women are on one side
of the you know of a wall and the men
are in the other and go
you know you do you it's a very narrow
it's a very narrow world view that
believes
that the the most important
situations that we have going on in
gender and equality right now are
occurring in the uk and in the usa
like you just need to look to the middle
east and and countries which
have a lot of work to do to realize that
that's not the case and i appreciate
that the world the sphere that everybody
lives in
is relative not absolute right like it's
just your problem compared with the
people in your immediate vicinity so
quite rightly so like everything is done
in relative terms
but yeah i i agree i think that there's
a lot of challenges at the moment just
in the dating market generally
and i want to get on to actually what
girls can do to kind of help
men in a second but just
finishing off those last two stages of
what we were talking about so men have
overcome approach anxiety
what can they do moving on to make sure
that they have good conversation any
stuff for body language and eye contact
and then
how can they escalate not upscale how
can they escalate
okay so it's called sexual escalation um
and this is a lot of guys what they
think
is they go right i need to approach the
girl build up comfort rapport get her
interested and then i need to sexually
escalate
yes but you should be sexually
escalating from the very beginning
now that doesn't mean trying to
physically turn her on
at the very beginning that's where men
and women are quite different
men are it's much more physical so i can
be talking to a guy
and it's quite platonic and not every
guy i'm not saying that but you know
you know just like an average guy if i
suddenly say let's go back to my house
and
everything's very put on like switch
down the light
for a bit of music give him a massage
and i can turn him on
okay the average guy because it's a
physical thing it's like oh
okay i'm stimulated that women are not
like that women don't tell you turn the
light down
change the mood give her give her a
massage and she's going to get horny
it's much more psychological so i say to
men look you can't just suddenly go
right
i'm going to flip the switch i'm going
to start being i'm going to escalate now
and just
get her you know aroused women can do
that to men much more easily than men do
that to women
what the man has to be doing when i say
escalating is he has to be
um sort of lacing the whole
interaction with little attraction
triggers okay
it's a more slow process so he's got to
for instance demonstrate high value
okay is this a man who has high value is
this a man
um who has other options is this a man
who's needy is this a man that can get
women if he wants
she's trying to assess all these things
on some level
whereas a man isn't with a woman he's
not
he's thinking is she
it's much more sort of black and white
but with a girl she's trying to
ascertain a lot of things
is her weirdo do other women find him
attractive um
is he confident in bed is he you know
it's all these things and you've got to
sort of drip feed
sort of clues to this throughout
and then you'll find that the transition
to actually escalating and
and getting her aroused is a lot easier
that makes sense what i say absolutely
yeah what are some of the ways that you
can drip
feed that is it touching her on the knee
when you say something is it i'm talking
about
what to say to her kind of thing so
maybe if you
okay so a physical one would be to stop
you know halfway and then sort of take a
look at her and say something like you
know now i know i'm attracted to you
now i know what it is but anyway you
could do something like that so it's
kind of
very playful in those early stages it's
playful flirty is he really flirting
with me
i'm not sure it's a bit of a chase you
know a bit of intrigue
um giving her a compliment
and then backing off like nothing's
happened that's push-pull
you can do things like that but what i'm
trying to say here
lots of different things you can do yes
the touching thing is you as you
mentioned but
uh i personally am someone that doesn't
really like to be touched that much i'm
just not a warm person
but a guy can really arouse me with his
words okay and his attitude
um so it does depend on the woman
slightly
okay um but yes flirting
um compliments the way that you
complement
um you know just showing her that you
have other options women really need to
know that women don't want to
be with a guy or sleep with a guy that
kind of know of a girl maybe once or
that maybe
the other thing is if the guy's showing
too much desperation or neediness is
everything that can get in the way when
it comes to sexual escalation
um placing too much value giving her way
too much value saying something like
i bet you get this all the time you know
something like that
just that's a kill demonstrating low
value
yeah yeah whereas if a woman does have a
man a man can always overlook it i've
noticed that when we get away with so
much more because the man is kind of
like
as you see he's more programmed like
he's shocked
he's also not playing that status value
game
right he's not playing the game that
like if you're attracted to a girl
it doesn't really matter if there's
other guys that are also attracted to it
oh no no no
yeah he just wants to get his lego i
know
it's very pretty to say we can be as
crass as you want on this program but he
just wants to like you know he wants to
um he wants to [ __ ] her and it's like i
have a guy's interest in her
who gives a [ __ ] i want to [ __ ] her um
you know does she have status i don't
care i wanna [ __ ] her you know
but because she's nice looking she's
quite hot and she's got a nice little
personality on her
um it's not the um
you know what they're expecting and i
don't mean this doesn't i'm not trying
to belittle men anyway
but i i think most guys people gonna be
honestly will agree
yes that is the case um whereas women
it's much more
they need they need proof and validation
their certainty that the guy's like this
that he's like that and then
they're trying to ascertain a lot more
that's what i'm trying to say women
i know that's with me i can meet a good
looking guy and if he's
if he's just good looking i won't just
sleep with a guy because he's good
looking i won't
whereas a man will a lot of men not all
fine
but a lot of men will just sleep with a
woman because she's hot
the only thing that they i think that's
i think that's why she's available
sometimes
that's a true a truth that everybody's
forgotten and it's an
asymmetry in the way that we work as
well and
again this highlights i think as we
move toward a world where some people
are trying to make it much more
egalitarian like almost completely
homogeneous between the genders
you're going to end up with challenges
because as you've identified there
like what a man looks for in attraction
with a woman is not the same as what a
woman looks for in a man and
what you identified that i thought was
really interesting was that you have
men um speaking to a woman in the way
that they
might find attractive as a man so
they're almost dating
other men they're like putting their own
dating brain inside of the girl and
saying right
i'm gonna attack me i'm gonna
proposition me
as her it's like no mate like you're
playing chess she's playing
[ __ ] exactly and i've learned that
with like how i seduce men
when i was young i didn't have a clue
what men want you know or anything but
now i know that
men like to chase i know they like to
chase and they i i think most men don't
want to be seduced
but what i do with guys is i will just
i'll i'll say something that will get in
their head
and it will it would just be something
an image that would stay in their head
and then i pull back
and then that's how i do it because i
know that they're operating on a
different way
to women um back to the point
you said that a lot of people are trying
to you know
um say men and women are the same let me
give you an example
all my male friends okay who i love
dearly
i have seen them at the end of the night
but these are good friends of mine
and it's against the end of the club and
there's a right scrubber
i'm like come on really and then i i
just need to [ __ ] for the sake of it i'm
like
really she looks like winnie the pooh
come on
and they're just like she's up for it
and he's a good looking guys
these are these are guys that you know
they they [ __ ] beautiful women
stunners but they will [ __ ] a winnie the
pooh
because it's there a woman you will
never see her
at the at the end of the night club
great i'll just take anything
him him over there that trunk guy he'll
do
you know if he can get it up i'm good
women don't think like that no but the
man's like there's a hole there's a
pulse
if he's in that move i'm doing it i had
rob henderson evolutionary psychologist
on the on the podcast talking about
dating and evolution and how it all ties
together
and he used this analogy which i think
is absolutely perfect he said that
men look for a reason why they wouldn't
sleep with a woman
women look for a reason why they would
sleep with a man and
the stats anyone that went back and
listened to that episode
men swipe right
8 out of 10 times and women swipe right
2 out of 10 times that's the stats on
tinder
the top 80 percent of women are
competing for the top 20
of men and the bottom 80 of men
are competing for the bottom 20 of women
this is stats
from tinder now you can dislike this as
much as you want as a guy or a girl but
facts don't care about your feelings
these are the stats out of the back end
of tinder what does that tell us it
tells us that hypergamy
women dating up and across is
challenging for both women
and for men there's more women competing
for a smaller pool of men
there's also this problem with women
becoming increasingly educated
increasingly rich because women often
don't want to date a guy who is better
educated and or richer than them
and if you increase the level at which
women are becoming
educated this isn't me saying like chris
you're telling them that they shouldn't
be educated no bollocks that's not what
i'm saying
obviously what i'm saying is that
because of the natural
um the natural attraction dynamic
where women tend to date up and across
they like higher social value they're
like a man that can demonstrate that
value
if you have tons and tons of value it's
like being the really tall girl
like if you're six foot as a girl
without heels
you're looking at pro basketball players
and stuff like you don't want to be able
to not wear heels at your wedding
you don't want to not to be dating a guy
that's shorter than you that just
happens to be
and if you take that rule and apply it
to
earnings and education it's kind of the
same
the higher that you move up the
hierarchy as a female the
smaller and smaller and smaller your
dating pool gets whereas as a guy
a guy will have a much broader dating
pool
okay but there's one exception to the
rule
and i'm in a really really good position
here so
i you know i'm gonna say yeah i earn a
lot of money and i'm successful and you
know i've got the big car and everything
and i know
it's yeah some guy you're absolutely
right most guys want someone
a woman that's successful in it i i
agree
but apart from younger men they they get
a massive kick out of it
and i like younger men
come on oh barely legal
[Laughter]
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore i just
apologize my friends just take a piss
out of me it's like
okay i don't care anymore i don't care
i do younger men that's it and they love
it
they love it you know they love them
they love the car
being picked up in the car and and um
you know
this you know
[Music]
um let's talk about the
uh those artifacts that pick apart these
three artifacts that
we spoke about earlier on anyone who
hasn't read neil strauss is the game or
kind of the um i guess the period from
what about 2000 to 2010
where kind of pick apart is three or
maybe a little bit later maybe like oh
three to kind of 13
where pick apart history and h
real social dynamics rsd max and all of
these sorts of guys like was smashing
youtube and putting his thoughts coming
out if you don't know who i'm talking
about just like
go go back in time by a decade and
you'll you'll see exactly what i mean
but being frank like even i as a
21 year old 22 year old hot-blooded male
looked at that stuff and i felt icky
like watching
youtube compilations of guys going up
and practicing day game which is just
going up and like kissing girls in a
[ __ ] park somewhere whilst some other
guy
youtube like videos it i'm like i
this there's something kind of weird
going on here and
with that having happened and perhaps
set the foundation for what is now your
industry
i can see why there is work to be done
in the teaching men to become attractive
and to date well
game to perhaps undo some of the kind of
unsavory stuff that happened a while ago
what's your thoughts
um i agree you shouldn't ever film
someone about their permission
i've never done that i've had some of my
trainers they said look you know can i
put something on your youtube channel we
approach a woman
absolutely not you do you you do what
you have to do but you know that's not
going on my channel
because i would hate something like that
to happen to me um but i do kind of get
why they did it
because people want to see evidence
because these guys you know they came
out of nowhere people like oh can you
actually do it
if you say yeah i can be like well
anyone can say that i need to see some
evidence so i can see it from a
marketing point of view why they
they want to do it um you know that oh
god it's so funny i have watched it
really really change
the pickup industry and it has gone much
more into self-help
but essentially you're still teaching
guys how to attract women you just you
know
using different terminology now um
people that would
the people that were teaching it then
they were people
who almost were self-taught and had gone
from literally
zero to doing okay
um but it's changed now most of the guys
that come you know walk through our door
are guys that are okay with women there
are some that have
not a clue quite a lot but there's a lot
of who are just like
they're doing okay but they just want to
do better and i actually asked them have
you read the game they never heard of it
so we're getting this new generation
coming through
people that just want to get better at
stuff and i think we're living now in a
culture where
people believe in self-improvement
they're much more open and honest about
it
so i think that's how it's changed a lot
there's no problem in the press with
someone saying i read james clear's
atomic habits though
but there is a problem with someone
saying i take
dating advice or i'm i'm taking a course
to help to pick up women i still think
there's a fair bit of stigma attached to
that
why is it it's changing it is changing a
little bit
um but yeah
it's still there but for women to learn
how to date men it's perfectly
acceptable have you seen all these
people popping up
teaching women how to date men i'm like
well why is that acceptable
you know why is that acceptable when
this isn't
i get it so i i thought about that
question a lot
i don't really know i think i i want to
know like we're not trying to get them
to bed women are trying to do something
much much more um sophisticated
trying to get a relationship well i'm
sorry that's much more manipulative than
getting someone into bed
get someone to want to be in a
relationship with you by any means
necessary like i will do
anything to get that man to put a
wedding ring on my finger
i'd be like god that's like some
hardcore manipulation there that you
have to do you'd be a completely
different person
getting someone into bed i think it's i
just don't think it's so manipulative
personally
so you're saying that the impact of
a short-term interaction by a guy being
more effective
is less than the impact of a long-term
interaction where a woman might
might take these tips and then use them
to have a five-year marriage with
someone
how many times have i heard my male
friend say as soon as i married her she
changed
she lost she put on weight that's number
one thing got really fat
how much had a drinking problem you know
i've heard it all i
i think men are the same you know a lot
of women marry men they go something's
changed but i think with
i've heard a lot of women have um
completely changed
they've got it you know they have got
they've got
the prize that's the ultimate prize for
women that they've married
i've done the whole marriage thing i
don't want to do it again but most women
they
they don't you know they get the
marriage like i'm good now i'm good i've
got someone to look after me take care
of me have children have a nice life
you'll love me no matter what you won't
divorce me now and men really would do
anything to avoid a divorce otherwise
hopefully i don't know why men even
marry anymore
i mean that's crazy
how much should men think about their
physical appearance
so we've talked a lot men how much
should men think about their physical
appearance like
physical appearance um
it is important um but you can't
become obsessed with it okay you've got
to do the best you can with yourself
um you know it's all about a good
impression
it does make a difference okay however
saying that i have um i'm very i'm a
very looks orientated person compared to
the average woman i'm
you know i i like an you know i like a
handsome guy and i
forgive a lot
of um i'll forgive a lot if he
if he has a nice face and a nice body
but even i will be like okay
there's a limit with that yeah it's so
boring that that face can allow you to
be
and equally i've been with men who are
really not attractive
not young not my type physically really
quite gross and i've been attracted to
them
so i always say to guys that gain will
gain good game um is much better than
being a type
much better it's much more powerful
um so yes make the best of yourself but
remember even if you make the best of
yourself you're not gonna be every
girl's type
she's just gonna say well at least he's
made an effort he looks half decent if
you're not her type
work on the game
it's much more scalable i suppose as
well the fact that if you have
if you're able to make people laugh i
mean [ __ ] hell like if you're able to
make people laugh
it's a superpower it doesn't matter
whether you're in a business meeting
whether you're
on a night out whether you're trying to
date a girl whether you're trying to
de-escalate a fight outside of a
nightclub
like if you can make people laugh
perfect example of this i was on love
island i was in the first season of love
island
oh yeah yeah i was first person through
the door when was the first season of
love island
five years ago it's been going on that
long has it
has indeed yeah although i guess we
haven't had a season this year so
yeah uh but yeah and john clark who's
now on towie
jonathan clark was on my season and he's
like
a big bigger lad like not
huge but like a bigger fan and it was
like everyone on there was like the
classic sort of reality tv
physique look and um
john got the playboy model the scouse
playboy model hannah
he got her because he's just got
bottomless charisma
like the guy is the guy is just cons
he's from essex got that like classic
sort of wide boy mentality
and he just goes and go he's got so many
stories really funny
center of attention despite the fact
that physically
you know there was guys on there that
were ex-bodybuilders and
professional ex-professional athletes
and all this sort of stuff but again
with that
john was demonstrating his value through
being able to make people laugh through
being personable and easy to relate to
and and funny you know he's a question
for you when you're on love island and i
appreciate that the girls
personally i don't i don't like the look
this instagram kind of weird face that
girls have but you know maybe that's
your thing
when you were there and you saw these
beautiful girls the one that you were
most attracted to was she the prettiest
one or was she the one with more game
so my season um i make the joke that our
season was kind of like a dress
rehearsal for the rest of them
um but i wasn't attracted to any of the
girls on my season which was the
challenge that i came up against and i
couldn't fake it
like i'm like no they were pretty i
didn't find them attractive
oh okay physically okay i didn't find
them i didn't find them physically
attractive i found some of them
interesting
but i didn't find them physically
attractive and that was a huge challenge
like going on a dating show and not
finding girls attractive is it but then
the the the show runners kept coming in
and saying because the guys
weren't being that forthcoming they had
real challenges like
a couple made it to the final of season
one of love island
as friends like you can't imagine that
happening now and the reason
i suggest that that happened was that
there was a mismatch between what the
producers were putting in for the girls
and what the producers were putting in
for the guys
and that must work in both directions to
a degree
but they kept on coming in and they were
saying uh so
what sort of girls are you attracted to
why are you not like how come you're not
so fussed about this that and the other
and a lot of the guys said well i tend
to sort of
prefer quite petite girls maybe girls
who go to the gym and this that and the
other
i [ __ ] you not season one of love island
had
amazon women like every girl in heels
was as tall if not taller than almost
all of the guys that were in there and
it's like
ah you know it's not
like the girls are they're great but
they're just not massively my
type and there's only so far that you
can kind of
push that
my ex-husband was very handsome but my
ex boyfriend before him
was really ugly he wasn't hideous he
wasn't quasimodo but he was quite an
ugly guy got any woman
but anyone uh
absolutely fearless playing to win all
the time
use jealousy plot lines and women
understood that jealousy
is makes women more attracted to guys
um he he was a force of nature in
himself but he
also was um he was he funny he was quite
funny not that funny but he had
so much banter so much better and he was
always escalating and he always had one
foot out the door
which means i'm not dependent on you i'm
not needy and women love her
women really love that they don't want a
guy to need them they want a guy to want
them
how does jealousy turn women on because
if a woman gets jealous
she's okay it's not that sorry
it's not so much that jealousy turns on
women it frustrates them but once the
woman
is feeling jealous it increases her
attraction it's like it's it's kind of
like um
it's linked to the fact that she thinks
she wants your attention and you're
giving it to another girl
that's the whole point if she doesn't
care about you and you're giving
attention don't give a [ __ ]
but you know if you can see right okay
this is working a little bit
she's she's you can't overkill it you
can't it's a fine balance also because
some guys don't that other way they're
just too much you know and it's like
it's all stick and no carrot there's got
to be
a little bit she's just got to fill in
order to appreciate you she's got to
feel
that um she can't second-guess you this
is really important any guys listening
out there
never let a woman second-guess you gotta
be like she's thinking okay so um i've
texted him so he'll text me in five
minutes like he always does
um you know everything is just
predictable everything he's going to do
is predictable
um he's a safe bet
they don't want it like i said don't go
too far the other way and say become the
bad boy or anything
but you know that old saying like treat
them mean to keep them keen
it actually it doesn't really mean be a
bastard to them it means just keep them
second guessing a little bit don't be
too predictable
um never ever get needy always show that
you have other options if she doesn't
want you
but that's really what it means yeah
alterations make a big difference
i understand i'd be again interested to
hear any girls that are listening if
they've
been with a guy dating a guy that they
found to be attractive
but then there was a some switch turned
on where he went into
needy predictable boring modes
and if that ended the attraction for you
um i wonder how many guys and girls
are sufficiently reflective about what
was and what wasn't successful about a
dating experience
it's quite easy for us to just oh well
she wasn't that this or he wasn't that
that and you know just like kind of
throw reasons around
whereas if you actually were to look at
what happened i'm gonna guess that a lot
of people would come upon
some of the realizations that you've
identified
yes and i think people need to be honest
so when i talk to girls and
or girls look when i talk one-on-one
with girls always like yes
yes sometimes when it's on social medias
it's like oh no no i only want a nice
guy or something like you know look at
the stats you know
loads of nice guys running around and
what is a nice guy what they're saying
is they want a good guy
okay that's not a nice guy having a good
man in your life i'm telling you he's
got an element to him
what's the difference between a good guy
and a nice guy okay so um
the good guy i'm going to simplify it
okay
the good guy shows elements of the bad
guy the bad guy shows elements of the
good guy and those
are the men who are successful okay and
then you've got people who are too good
and they end up nice category and then
you've got
the bad guys who are too bad and they
become one-dimensional
so it's doing a blender so if you say
look i'm one of those people i like to
treat women well i like to hold open the
door get the bill for them
i like that i respect women that's who i
am good let's work with that okay
but make sure that you're not so good
that you're not sexually escalating
that you're being really safe with what
you're saying you're not voicing your
opinions
um little tip for the guys who are
really like i really respect women
is to you know to counterbalance that
with being a bit of a bad boy in bed
this is very interesting
it's that it's that contrast that's very
attractive
so i went a day and i'm going to be
quite personal here
well i had a boyfriend and he was you
know the good guy
very polite everything and it was
getting a bit kind of like a little bit
of spice here
and he led oh he went over during our
dinner and i was kind of like in that
moment saying
you know what this is not really working
out and he said i can't wait to
[ __ ] you later really hard and i was
like
oh right okay that's what i was looking
for okay
but if it had been a bad guy like a kind
of you know a bit of a
bad guy feel which i date also i can do
both
and he started saying that to maybe like
oh please it's like
the same it's overkill so
the bad guy what is interesting is women
will go for a bad guy because you'll
show that the
sensitive side in bed or the vulnerable
side
and it's that contrast so flipping it
around
um when i speak to men a lot of guys say
look i like the alpha dominant woman
i said yes but i bet you like it to be
quite submissive in bed and you like her
to be like quite vulnerable when no
one's looking and they're like yes
because it's a contrast if they're going
to go for a very dominant alpha woman
and she's dominant and alpha in bed
there's no other side and it becomes
boring i've had to learn
to do that because i'm quite like tough
and direct and i noticed that
the guys that really like me are the
guys who've seen my vulnerable side
but when i hide that vulnerable side
from guys
they're like you know what one
dimensional let's call it a day love
you know that's my tip for guys out
there you want to be the good guy go for
it
that's your thing and i encourage that i
don't try and change people like that
but my god you need to show a different
element to keep her on her toes
i love that so finishing up what dating
and attraction advice do you have for
women we've given a lot for men this
evening what are the
what are the things that women can do to
either help men be better daters or to
be better daters themselves
to help men become better daters
well obviously as we've said this
evening like as a you know a high level
thing that i've noticed
is if a guy comes over if you're single
and a guy comes over
and you're with your group of
girlfriends don't keep your back turned
to him when someone comes up because
it's the same girls that i know because
i've seen i've had
two thousand three thousand people work
for me over the last ten years and
they've all been between the ages of 18
and 21
and during that time you have more
relationships and you do lectures
and the girls that complain about being
single
about not being able to find a good guy
are the ones who when they're on a night
out with their girlfriends
and a guy comes up and tries to talk to
them we'll give him this sort of weird
sneering like kind of you like this
it's that yeah that overlapping that
over the shoulder thing and it's like
well [ __ ] hell darling
like do you want do you want to have
like do you want to give a guy a chance
or do you want to look cool in front of
your [ __ ] mates
give him a chance this is my advice for
ladies out there
throw him a really interesting question
oh great question something really good
that gives him that open goal that
opportunity and if he [ __ ] up he [ __ ]
up his loss
what like um i'd say something like um
oh god i'm generally very nice to guys
that speak to me
i'm really quite a nice person i guess
it's a dating as a dating coach you're
never going to be
a prick to guys that are trying to do
the thing i've never been able
to guys but even when i was younger i
was never i don't know one of those
people that just
you know i could be ruthless when the
time was up i'd be like okay done
but i was never like someone came to i
never went like that and never i just
think it's a horrible thing to do to
another human being it's vile when
people do that
horrible why do that um
i would ask something like um i said say
listen what's your favorite film
i really would i would just like very
corny and
[ __ ] dorky like that because
if they're gonna [ __ ] say to me
shawshank redemption
or that other bloody film that men love
uh what's it called one of leonardo
dicaprio and it's
just a terrible film that every man
loves what's that
inception or something done i'll just
say look i'm sorry i'm done
i gave you i gave you give me the chance
oh you could say something like you know
what would you do and why do you love it
give them the opportunity you can really
give them a chance right what are they
going to say they say
funny witty or they're just going to go
i'm going to carry on playing it really
nice and safe and then you can think
okay
just like you don't be honest that's
nice for you i have to go now or
something
but at least you know the guys like had
that chance at least
that's cool i i think one thing that i
hope girls take away from this
i know we've given a lot of advice i
promise you i'm trying to find a
guy or a girl that can come on and can
do the same thing for girls i think
there's an awful lot
that both genders have to learn from
hearing dating advice for the other side
i know that girls have just had to sit
through an hour of like learning like oh
this is how guys can pick up other girls
but there's a lot of insights that you
can glean from that as well right to
reflect on yourself oh maybe
maybe that's the way that i am maybe
it's this the main thing that i'd love
girls to take away
from this i can tell you something for
girls
men are very vulnerable don't believe
all that kind of
they come to me they're very vulnerable
and most of them really are looking for
love and that's not me being corny
and trying to finish on a high note yeah
they want to screw around they want to
[ __ ] and they all [ __ ] a scrubber you
know
no no question but deep down they really
are looking they say
i'm looking for a girlfriend i'm looking
for the one
i think that every you know there's it's
easy to tar men with one brush right to
say
the way that men act between the age of
17 and 25
is just you can extrapolate that for the
rest of time and it's like well
obviously not
but evidently that goes down and stuff
you know
i think the libido is a big part of it i
mean a 39 year old man
has not got the libido of an 18 year old
it just does not so that means okay he
likes sex but it's not that
everything's about getting a quick shag
you know
it's it's not that anymore it's about
something else it's about yes good
sex but with in a loving relationship
and that changes
the requirements or what a man is
looking for so yeah i think you're using
your tits using that model
like that whatever you have experienced
as a girl
as a young dating uh in the the dating
world between the ages of whatever 18 25
or maybe 1830 or something like that
and then extrapolating that forward just
running that same script
and thinking that this is the way that
it's going to be for the rest of time
like you have to appreciate that that's
not going to be the case
but the main thing that i want girls and
guys to take away from this
is that it's [ __ ] terrifying for most
guys to go up and talk to a girl
like it really really is a big deal i
know that that's so
lame and it's like such a wet thing to
say that oh my god you went up and spoke
to a girl like
but we've just identified there's bomb
disposal experts firemen and policemen
out there
who are scared of saying hi
my name's john um can i buy you a drink
like you know the fact that you've got
that says absolutely everything
and hopefully today we're going to have
taught guys look
here are some ways that you can over
overcome approach anxiety you need to
have
expand that domain of competence do
progressive overload make yourself
become less
sensitive to it you need to escalate you
need to have things to say
and girls on the flip side of that it's
like be receptive to it
you know if a guy comes up to unless
you're in a relationship or whatever and
even that can be done with a bit of
class and grace
right like you you don't need to give
the guy who you're not going to be in a
relationship with anyway
the like the that show i can't do the
shoulder thing you know the shoulder
thing i mean
yeah yeah i can't do it girls every girl
is innately born with the
do the dirty look over the shoulder
skill um but yeah guys guys don't have
it
but like don't give them that like that
guy might have plucked up a [ __ ] ton
of courage to come and speak to you
and the fact that you're in a
relationship right now should mean that
you should hope
like help that person to get to what a
relationship as opposed to
this thing that people in [ __ ]
relationships do and guys do it as well
but girls do a lot where because they're
in a relationship they use it as a
yardstick to beat
single guys with it's almost like a guy
can come up and they don't need to
engage and they can
almost be really really vicious with the
way that they respond
because they're like well i've got a
boyfriend and it's like yeah you [ __ ]
wouldn't have acted this way six months
ago
six months ago if that guy come up to
you you wouldn't have [ __ ]
yeah so smug so just be
more [ __ ] gracious man and this
doesn't mean what's one of the main
things that we've said today
you need to have this polarity you need
to have this masculine and feminine
energy going on
you need to not just be the one thing
across the board this
homogenous playing i love that thing
what was it
not playing to win what is that don't
play it okay so most people are playing
not to lose need to play to win it's
game theory it's gambling
i love that so i think and that you know
a lot of people they're so terrified
and again like if a guy's done that it's
probably because he's plucked up a
[ __ ] ton of courage
to come over and speak to you with your
group of girlfriends all wearing pretty
little thing dresses
with like you know you red bottoms on
like be gracious about it yeah you don't
know the back story absolutely
uh you just don't he could be a dick
sure but he also could be someone
suffering from
really bad anxiety and you're the first
person he's ever spoken to
you know in his whole life you don't
know the backstory i i've never i've
just never been horrible to a guy that's
approached me i mean i've been kind of
like
you know i've got to go thank you but
i've never been
i've never done that look i've never
done it it's really
it's funny even some of my friends we
just i don't hang on them
those kind of people much i don't know i
would say to you
yeah i think i'm thinking this person's
not for me i just know it's not
i'm always kind of like you know thank
you but no thank you but
maybe if there's in a situation
how do you think what can guys do to
help other guys date and what can girls
do to help other girls date is there
anything that you think that they can
they can do like how can you gas your
friends up so that they go over and
speak to someone
because it's not often like have you
ever here's a good one for you
the number of girls have come over to me
and said hey
uh my friend over there thinks that
you're really whatever whatever this is
it's all right [ __ ] hell like that's
that that is such a
because what do you do because the girls
still sat with all of her friends do you
go over and just like appear within the
group of friends that have all been
talking about you i'll just say well
tell her to come over here
i'll just said that great point showing
value
you've got to show that if you go there
you're going to the lion's den
it's on her turf it's like that's her
her territory
if she you know just say to yeah she's
she's gorgeous
give her that that bit of encouragement
yeah she's gorgeous your friend tell her
to come over
just that that's that's all i would say
because you if you just say oh tell her
to come over
um the girl might be a bit nervous also
like
what if you know what what if he doesn't
like me but if you've said oh she's
gorgeous
okay fine she's gonna have that
confidence to come over to you because
women can be a bit nervous too women are
a bit all this also trust me
that's why you're a professional what
can guys do anything that guys can do to
help their mates
oh um not really it's it's awful for a
guy to come over and say my friend likes
you it's not even cute
it's okay if he's young he's 18 it's
fine
but the best thing to do is um
actually one of the best things that we
did we did this experiment
we went out with one of our students and
i put him with one of my wing guys
i said just trust me i said just trust
me what i'm going to tell him to say
about you so there were some girls at
the table
when he went he could feel that there
was no interest being built but when he
when the student went
because i got this don't worry he said
listen my friend
he's like he's such a player it's like
it's best that you're
kind of avoiding him he's just a total
player
um but anyway and then when he got back
the girl was really
interested in him because she'd already
heard this it was like
he's like you said that he's like yeah
it's working don't worry about it
but the other thing guys please enter
girls if you have a male friend
please please if you have a male friend
you want to set him up someone never
ever introduced me
he's a really nice guy
[Laughter]
so you know what he's he's a good guy
um be careful of him be careful you
could do that sort of wink and
you you'll find that the girl's much
more interested i know he's a nice guy
that means oh
god they've set him up with everybody
he's been single for a while
it's just big red flashing lights right
yeah little things like that
um i see so many women people women and
men do it and they just
he's a really nice guy like just stop
yeah
if there was ever a way to just ruin
your friends dating chances
but again like that comes from firstly a
place of good intentions but secondly
a complete misunderstanding of how
dating dynamics work
so today today you've taught people some
things that are hopefully going to stop
them from being quite so [ __ ] both guys
and girls
if people want to find out more guys
want to take it to the next level where
should they go
okay go to my website kezia noble.com
um i'm also on instagram twitter
facebook youtube um yeah subscribe to my
youtube channel that's where most
information is coming from
75 million views in accounting oh
wow that means there's demand out there
75 million views
five million guys thinking
[ __ ] sake wait maybe it's just one guy
watching it 75 million times
that's what i think it is just this one
very very
single it's just me watching my own
videos
exactly the same thing that i do look
everything that we've spoken about will
be linked in the show notes below
including
kezia's website what have you you got a
seven day challenge what stuff have you
got if
you want to do them i have the um if you
don't want to
um you know come over to london and
we've got the
home training acceleration home training
program
and if you do want to get your hands
dirty
uh you want to check out the seven-day
mastery program which we had to stop to
do the lockdown but now we've reopened
and um we're already really busy
um actually it's such a good time to
meet women i've noticed it like
everyone's talking to each other because
they're like i'm free i'm out
finally i've got some [ __ ] social
contact again
these are real like we these these
programs that i'm running we don't just
create slight
kind of like supplemental shifts i mean
these are mental breakthroughs these are
huge
um we've got so many video testimonials
that's why i always say to people look
you know
it's not me just saying that i've got
hundreds of video testimonials go to our
website look at the video testimonials
then
guys from every walk of life being
really honest putting their faces out
there
and saying this has completely changed
my life so um i hope to do the same
for you fine not you
but anyone disney hey i'm single i'm
single as [ __ ] as well so i need all the
help you can get look thank you
so much for coming on it's been awesome
i've really really enjoyed it hopefully
everyone's taking something away
i want to know what you think like is
the dating world [ __ ] at the moment
is it completely terrible and do we need
kezia's help desperately also
if anyone's got any suggestions for who
i can get on as a
dating coach for women like leave it
below i'll try and get in touch with
them and i'll try and get them on as
well then we can we can learn the
equivalent red pills for girls that
we've just learned for guys
[Music]
you